we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p the Eggman
called in we haven't heard from the
Eggman much if you're not familiar with
the Eggman the Eggman is a former
federal convict who did some time for
completely nonviolent drug charges
remember that nonviolent he's a good guy
and he calls in every once in a while he
believes that Joe Biden will crush Trump
in Florida here's why he believes that
hey Dave I love when you have Bill share
on the guy is great he's super smart
he's dead right about Florida Florida is
definitely gonna vote Biden over Trump I
have two reasons for this the first
reason is when Trump was in New York
resident New York did not vote for him
okay but understand that New York is far
more liberal than Florida so so far it's
not a great argument from the eggman but
let's continue who rejected him we voted
iller II now that he's Florida's problem
as in greta's they are Florida is gonna
reject Trump I'm telling you this it's
gonna just so he may be right but
Florida is just the redder state than
New York so I don't know that it's a
good comparison if you know if if Trump
moved to Massachusetts Massachusetts
isn't voting for Trump so I don't know
how much the residency is going to be a
factor okay
also my dad is an old Jew in a
retirement community and they've all
loved Biden they don't give a crap about
any allegations anything terror who they
are voting Biden damn I have six baby
chicks that are tickin and I'm gonna
have eggs and a chicken coop this year
sometimes one turns out to be a rooster
if I have a rooster I'm gonna name them
after you brother David Pakman but
hopefully I won't Shalom brother hi pal
right Shalom to the egg man and yeah by
the way
the rooster thing just reminded me I've
been getting some videos from viewers of
their pets who like watching the show so
there's a Portuguese dog I don't mean a
Portuguese water dog like the breed just
a dog in Portugal who watches the David
Pakman show every day with rapt
attention and I got a video of it and a
bunch of people have been we're gonna do
a compilation of these if you have a pet
that likes watching the David Pakman
show
please get video of it and send
it to me we would love to see it and
include it in our upcoming compilation
on the bonus show today Republicans are
now trying to win that California
special election that we've talked about
many times before I'm going to talk to
you about that we will also talk about
us grocery costs we often talk about
deflationary spirals when we talk about
recessions possibly depressions like the
one we are in or may soon be an but
there are areas elements of society
where we have seen significant inflation
of prices groceries are one of those
areas we're going to talk about that
also on today's bonus show the Georgia
Governor Brian Kemp now says Georgia
drivers who got their licenses without a
road test are going to have to
eventually take that road test I want to
talk about where this all came from and
the implications don't miss today's
bonus show for our members only sign up
at join pakman.com or at patreon.com
slash david pakman show huge bonus show
I will be joined by producer Pat Ford
and there will be much discussion very
much talking I will put it that way